quatre gammes de températures 15 25
degrés 5° -20° -82 là on est comme moi
c'est moins 80 qui matin le ministre de
la santé tout sourire mardi dernier
olive et veyran son déplacement au coeur
de la plateforme logistique de
chanteloup en brie en seine et marne
la france prête à recevoir des millions
de premières doses du vaccin files
heures biotech contre le coronavirus
avec des supers congélateur ça me donne
quand même une idée de du volume de
stockage grâce si énorme que sa langue
le compte à rebours a commencé en
réalité depuis le départ de ces petites
fioles de belgique et des laboratoires
pfizer de possibilités d'acheminement
ensuite dans l'hexagone réception des
deux au sein de six plateformes
spécialisées comme celle de chanteloup
ambri autre possibilité des dépôts
ouverts une centaine de sites dont la
plupart hospitalier un par département
avec toujours les précieux congélateur
pour les garder au frais
l'un des chars une fois qu'il est sorti
la carte 4 5 jours pour
annie serait pas que sa réputation
là maintenant leur commence à tourner
imaginons que c'est pas que ça ils
doivent aller au bout justement on va au
bout de la région
moins de douze heures de transport
autorisé un stockage ont lieu sécurisé
possible
puisse être ensuite envoyées directement
en l'occurrence dans l'ehpad pouvait
être administré en moins de cinq jours
au total la population des ehpad cible
numéro 1 du gouvernement plus de 14000
collectif pour personnes âgées en
métropole et outre-mer sont concernés
une première phase qui devrait s'étendre
jusqu'en février avec la réception de
plus de trois millions de doses d'un
horizon de 24 à 48 heures nous
diffuserons un guide de recommandations
de bonne pratique pour les
établissements accueillant des personnes
âgées dépendantes pour les ehpad
s'agissant de la vaccination et des
modalités de recueil du consentement
nous avons fait le choix en france qui
est un choix qui est assumée revendiquée
de prendre le consentement des personnes
qui seront vaccinés la vaccination n'est
pas obligatoire de faire un examen
médical préalable une deuxième étape
entre février et mars 2021 pour certains
professionnels de santé et personnes
présentant notamment des pathologies
chroniques troisième phase à la fin du
printemps la vaccination sera ouverte
aux 50 millions de français restant avec
en ligne de mire les secteurs les plus
exposés comme ceux de la santé
l'éducation et celui de l'alimentaire de
repos ce succès obligatoire martel au
gouvernement mais un futur projet de loi
sur les urgences sanitaires qui fait
polémique
le premier ministre pourrait à l'avenir
suspendre certains déplacements des
français
un test de dépistage un traitement ou
encore l'administration d'un vaccin
deviendraient nécessaires
que cache emmanuel macron je croyais
naïvement que dans notre patrie le
respect des libertés étaient la règle et
ses restrictions l'exception là
l'exécutif aurait tout pouvoir pour
suspendre nos libertés sans contrôle du
parlement
inconcevable de façon sournoise ce texte
envisage non pas de rendre la
vaccination obligatoire mais d'empêcher
toute vie sociale aux personnes qui ne
le serait pas quand il s'agit de
restreindre nos libertés publiques
on pourrait avoir une discussion
collective tout de même face à cette
fronde le gouvernement fera promis que
ce projet de loi ne serait pas examinée
devant le parlement avant plusieurs mois
et la fin de la crise a dit